i'd like to
correct something on for the record now
i'm i
over the years every once in a while i
see some jackass facts and it'll be like
um when when chris first met stevo he
didn't initially like stevo
that was a total lie like i actually did
like and i i don't even know if i don't
think you believed that but
i did like you when i first met you when
did you guys excuse me
um in florida um i did like you
i think there was a thing when you were
boxing with ryan dunn where i was like
stevo
i don't like the man um i hope ryan wins
or something like that
like it was like something like that and
then some other thing it was one of
those things that got way blown out of
proportion
but i did like you when i first met you
and i wanted everyone listening to know
that
that uh yeah it was just an incorrect
fact all right and it bothered me
well i appreciate that and i remember it
well and thank you for asking paul
pontius and i met for the first time
when jackass had been ordered to series
it was
it was it started out as a pilot and
then when uh
when i first filmed for the series i was
still working in the circus
and pontius came with jeff tremaine with
johnny knoxville with the whole
mtv crew they filmed me in the circus
that day
i uh swallowed the goldfish then that
night we stapled
the letters of jackass onto my butt
cheeks and then after uh
after filming after the bar
the wee hours of the morning pontius and
i went to a diner
uh i hope it was an ihop okay
yeah the international house of pancakes
yeah so it was far
like i was hungry i think i suggested it
but we ended up walking there
right and wherever that that was but god
it was far it wasn't
you know yeah it was it was somewhere at
that point we were down in miami and it
was still that very first night
yeah i ordered um
but here here's what i do remember is
that uh while we were eating
at ihop i i you know and this is after
the longest [ __ ] day and then getting
drunk and then
i mean who knows what time it was and uh
i'm telling like the the weight triggers
everybody
in the ihop hey you want to see a trick
you're going to see
let me do a back flip let me do it like
i'll put a cup on my head and i'll drink
it with no hands i don't know
and pontius is just like dude
like stop
oh yeah like we got back and like we
were at the hotel on the balcony and
like this
the hotel like it was a motel part of
that hotel
the motel security like came rolling up
and you're like
you like jumped off the balcony or you
jumped off like the the
second story thing and you're like it's
cool dude and you did like a press-up to
handstand like
like like that dress up the hand stand
explained why it was cool that we were
like still like running around
and he's like um he's like oh yeah dude
i met you before i bought you you did
backflip i bought you drinks at a bar
um after you did a backflip or something
like that right and um
the guy actually met you it was funny
though but um
and um then the next day we bonded over
a conversation about
porn um we were both we were talking
about how
um we didn't care we didn't lesbian porn
didn't do much for us
because um we agreed it was like looking
at skateboard magazine
and just looking at skate spots with no
one riding them right
right i still feel that way don't you oh
it's so funny i love lesbian porn i mean
dude lesbian porno scenes in the porno
it's like how we used to deal with the
vert scenes
you know like yeah just fast forward
that
it it's fine it's fine to see naked
ladies but
but it's like i don't know it's yeah
it's like it's like
looking at a bunch of skate parks with
no one riding them right
i wouldn't say a closed skate park but
just escape
a skate park maybe in the rain yeah
right i remembered too after we ate at
that diner
and we were on the long walk back to the
hotel
um you were kind of telling me what
jackass was gonna be like
like what our roles were you said uh
knoxville's gonna do a bunch of stuff
like every episode and each of the rest
of us will get like one
like one bit you know we're going to be
kind of you know and i had no idea what
it was going to be like and
so we did bond in that regard like there
was sort of a
a kinship of being um what do you call
it like supporting cast members
yeah dude